hi guys I'm Ralph from simple on and
today I'd like to welcome you all to the
greatest debate of the century today I'm
joined by two giants of the cloud
computing industry they'll be going
head-to-head with each other to decide
who amongst them is better it's going to
be one hell of a fight now let's meet
our candidates on my left we have EWS
who's voiced by a picture hi guys and on
my right we have Microsoft Azure whose
voice by Anjali hey there so today we'll
be deciding who's better on the basis of
their origin and the features they
provide their performance in the present
day and comparing them on the basis of
pricing market share options free tier
and instance configuration now let's
listen to their opening statements let's
start with AWS launched in 2006 AWS is
one of the most commonly used cloud
computing platforms across the world
companies like Adobe Netflix Airbnb HTC
Pinterest and Spotify have put their
faith in AWS for the proper functioning
it also dominates the cloud computing
domain with almost 40% of the entire
market share so far nobody's even gotten
close to beating that number
AWS also provides a wide range of
services that covers the great number of
domains domains like compute networking
storage migration and so much more now
let's see what Azure has to say about
that Asha was launched in 2010 and is
trusted by almost 80 percent of all
fortune 500 companies the best of the
best companies in the world choose to
work only with Asha Asha also provides
its services to more regions than any
other cloud service provider in the
world
Raja covers 42 regions already and 12
more are being planned to be made as
also provides more than hundred services
spanning a variety of domains now that
the opening statements are done let's
have a look at the current market status
of each of our competitors this is the
performance chart here we have the stats
for the market share of AWS Azure and
other cloud service providers this is
for the early 2018 period Amazon Web
Services takes up a whopping 40% of the
market share closely followed by is your
30% and other cloud services adding 30%
this 40% indicates most organizations
clear interest in using AWS VR number
one because of our years of experience
and trusts we've created among our users
sure you're the market leader but we are
not very far behind let me remind you
more than 80% of the fortune 500
companies trust a job with the cloud
computing needs so it's only a matter of
time before a jaw takes the lead the
rest of the 30% that is an AWS or as
your accounts to the other cloud service
providers like Google cloud platform tax
pays IBM SoftLayer and so on now for our
next round the comparison Rock first
will be comparing pricing we'll be
looking at the cost of a very basic
instance which is a virtual machine of
two virtual CPUs and agb's of RAM for
AWS this will cost you approximately
0.09 to eight US dollars per R and for
the same instance in Azure it will cost
you approximately 0.09 six US dollars
per our next up let's compare market
share and options as I mentioned before
AWS is the undisputed market leader when
it comes to the cloud computing domain
taking up 40% of the market share by
2020 AWS is also expected to produce
twice its current revenue which comes
close to forty four billion dollars not
to mention AWS is constantly expanding
it's already strong roster of more than
hundred services to fulfill the shifting
business requirements of organizations
all that is great really good for you
but the research company Gartner has
released a Magic Quadrant that you have
to see you see the competition is now
neck to neck between ashore and AWS it's
only a matter of time before a jar can
increase from its 30 percent market
share and surpass AWS this becomes more
likely considering how all companies are
migrating from AWS to Azure to help
satisfy their business needs as yours
not far behind
AWS when this comes to services as well
as yours service offerings are
constantly updated and improved on to
help users satisfy their cloud computing
requirement now let's compare a double
yes
free offerings AWS provides a
significant number of these services for
free helping users get hands-on
experience with the platform products
and services the free tier services fall
under two categories services that will
remain free forever and the others that
are valid only for one year they always
free category offers more than 20
services for example Amazon SMS sqs
cloud watch etc and valid for a year
category offers approximately 20
services for example Amazon s3 ec2
ElastiCache etc both types of services
have limits on the usage for example
storage number of requests compute time
etc but users are only charged for using
services that fall under the valid for a
year category after a year of their
usage a show provides a free tier as
well it also provides services that
belong to the categories of free for a
year and always free there are about
twenty five-plus always free services
provided by Usher
these include app service functions
container service Active Directory and
lots more and as of the valid for a year
there are eight services offered
there's Linux or Windows virtual
machines blob storage SQL database and
few more Roger also provides the users
with credits of two hundred US dollars
to access all the services for 30 days
now this is a unique feature that Azure
provides where users can use their
credits to utilize any service of a
choice for the entire month now let's
compare instance configuration the
largest instance that AWS offers is that
of a whopping 256 GB of RAM and 16
virtual CPUs the largest that as your
office isn't very far behind either 224
GBS of ram as 16 virtual CPUs and now
for the final round each of our
contestants will be shown facts and they
have to give explanations for these
facts we call it the rapid-fire round
first we have features in which AWS is
good and azure is better AWS does not
cut down on the features it offers its
users however it requires slightly more
management on the user's part
yo goes slightly deeper with the
services that fall under certain
categories like platform as a service
and infrastructure as a service next we
have hybrid cloud where it abuse is good
and Azure is better okay although AWS
did not emphasize on hybrid cloud
earlier they are focusing more on
technology now sure has always
emphasized on hybrid cloud and has
features supporting it since the days of
its inception for developers
it abuse is better and Azure is good of
course it's better because AWS supports
integration with third-party
applications well as your provides
access to data centers that provide a
scalable architecture for pricing both
AWS an azure are at the same level it's
good for AWS because it provides a
competitive and constantly decreasing
pricing model and in the case of a job
it provides offers that are constantly
experimented upon to provide its users
with the best experience and that's it
our contestants have finished giving
their statements now let's see who won
surprisingly nobody each cloud computing
platform has its own pros and cons
choosing the right one is based entirely
on your organization's requirements and
with that we've reached the end of
another video I hope you guys found this
informative and helpful thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simpler hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turner up and get certified click
here